i do have to get to a little bit of good
news right now
about the election which is which is a
good poll
for president trump but before i get
that i want to cross the pond head on
over
to the united kingdom because there is a
british
member of parliament who is
focusing in on one of the key sources of
rot
in our civilization and in our culture
and it's affecting not just the u.s
not just the uk it's affecting the whole
western world and that this is something
called
critical race theory comes from critical
theory you've heard us
mention this on the show a little bit
sometimes critical theory is
actually pretty simple theory the theory
is to criticize this was developed
by neo-marxists in the 1920s 30s and 40s
really though it developed out of the
frankfurt school especially in the 1930s
and 40s
and the idea is to engage in what marx
called the ruthless criticism of
everything that exists
this is where we get political
correctness from in large part
the idea that we're going to completely
subvert the old standards of our
civilization
so there's this great mp uh dawn butler
in the uk or i'm sorry
the mp dawn butler is a labor mp
but the women and equalities minister
kemi badanok
is uh is calling
out this critical race theory take a
listen to this absolute evisceration
curriculum does not need decolonizing
for the simple reason that it is not
colonized
we should not apologize for the fact
that british children primarily study
the history of these islands and it goes
without saying that the recent fad
to decolonize maths decolonize
engineering decolonize the sciences that
we have seen across our universities
to make race the defining principle of
what is studied
is not just misguided but actively
opposed to the fundamental purpose of
education
the curriculum by its very nature is
limited there are a finite number of
hours to teach any subject
and what we haven't heard in this debate
from those members who want
more added to it on both sides of the
house is what necessarily must be taken
out
perhaps we'll get to that on another day
i love this point
and it's one that i don't hear
conservatives making and we should all
listen to this lady
which is what the left says when they
want to get rid of shakespeare at yale
and as a course requirement in the
english department or they want to get
rid of chaucer
or whatever or they want to teach some
bs revisionist history instead of the
real history
what they say is we want to expand the
curriculum
we want to decolonize the curriculum
which
the idea that you're going to decolonize
the english department
by taking shakespeare out i think maybe
you don't understand the meaning of the
word colonize
i don't colonize is when you
have a power go into a foreign land and
control it shakespeare is not foreign to
english shakespeare in many ways
invented the english language he's
certainly contributed greatly to our
modern
english the idea that because you've got
old white guys in an english curriculum
that's colonization
it's very silly when you remember that
uh the english people
are white and writers for most of
history have been men
and good writers are dead generally
speaking because there have been
a lot more there's been a lot more time
in the
history of the english language than
what we're living in right now
she hits on all of that but then she
goes to this point she says
we can't just kind of
outsource this idea and say well we'll
expand it we'll just have choice and
maybe some people want to read
shakespeare maybe some people want to
read i don't know slam poetry and you
know we'll just have choice and choice
and choice
you can't do that there are only so many
hours in the day
you yourself the educator have to make
choices
every extra minute you spend reading
slam poetry you're
not going to be reading shakespeare
every minute you spend reading the 1619
project
you're not going to be reading true
history
you have to make those choices education
is limited education is coercive
you've got to teach people things
sometimes you're the slogan
that it's not that we want to teach
people what to think we we just want to
teach them how to think but that is a
completely meaningless slogan
you cannot teach people how to think
without teaching them what to think
if i want to teach people how to think
about mathematics i have to teach them
that two plus two equals four that's a
fact that i'm teaching them
if i want to teach someone how to think
about ethics and philosophy i have to
teach them that
it is wrong to commit murder or that it
is wrong to steal
and you know the left has no problem
with this the left will teach you that
it is not wrong to commit murder through
abortion or that it is not wrong to
steal through
confiscatory policies or outright
looting that's what they're going to
tell you
and then that's going to teach you how
to think and
if you have that kind of an education
it's going to it's not going to teach
you
how to think very well it does matter
what we teach we have to get
past this idea that we're afraid to make
substantive moral statements
that we're afraid to say to suppress
stupid views
we do we have to if you're going to
teach the 2 plus 2 equals 4
you have to suppress the stupid view the
two plus two equals five
if you're going to teach that america
was founded in 1776 or 1620 for that
matter
you you have to suppress you have to
shut down you have to reject the stupid
view that america was founded
in 1619. that is how you teach people
that lady in the uk gets it we should
get it over here
as well i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts